- [Announcer] This UCSD TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website, or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked large-brained. Long the
master of fire, tools and language. But
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Carol] What I'm going to do is either
it can be considered as a sobriety
checkpoint or something completely crazy,
but I've been given some might consider
the enviable task of talking about the
evolution of early human body form and
particularly in the context of
understanding shapes of everything from
the neck down associated with the origins
of genus Homo. Now we have this idea about
the transition from australopithecus to
Homo. When we look at australopith
skeletons we see they're different from
ours. They tend to be smaller in body
size, males are much, much larger than
females. We tend to see that they seemed
to have shorter lower limbs, longer upper
limbs. They have longer, more curved
fingers and toes. They look pretty
different in body form and we have the
idea that to go from something like an
australopith to something like us involved
a series of changes that we see when we
make a comparison like this. And sure
enough, when we look at some of the early
Homo erectus fossils like this beautiful
Turkana boy from Kenya, he's about 1.6
million years old. We see that he also
seems to share some of those features of
the post cranial skeleton that we see in
humans and that he seems to have more
human-like limb proportions with longer
stronger legs, bigger lower limb joints,
smaller upper limbs, thinner body form. So
this transition has shaped our ideas about
what the adaptive changes would have been
to go from point A to point B. Because
after all, if we're trying to understand
why and how our genus evolved, we need to
know what changes happened. Did they
happen together? Did they happen as a
package, were some of the features
evolving at different times in different
places? Those are the data that we have to
come up with our ideas about why it all
happened. So when we look at something
like this, we see australopiths here. They
sort of had the stocky ape shape. They're
maybe living partly in the trees. And then
we have these more savanna-dwelling,
animals that may have been doing long
distance walking and running, using fancy
pants stone tools, all kinds of things.
But in terms of the post cranial skeleton,
some of the features that we think of with
this transition that fuels our adaptive
ideas is have to do with changes in limb
proportions, changes in lower limb joint
size, changes in the shape of the torso,
changes in body size and dimorphism or
difference between males and females. So
what I'd like to do today is take you
through a little bit of the evidence we
have and there's only a little bit to talk
about so I won't be up here very long, to
see first of all was australopithecus
different from what we think of as Homo as
we thought. And I'm also going to talk a
little bit about what we have from the
earliest part of the Homo fossil record in
the way of post cranial bones that may
tell us something about what was
happening. So we'll start with
australopiths because that's the easy
part, we have more fossils. If you open up
any human evolution textbook you'll see a
picture something like this where you look
at the body shape of the torso of
australopithecus and you see this
reconstruction. This is based on fossils
done 35 or 40 years ago. There are more
fossils that have come in to change our
ideas a little bit. But you see, the
stocky anamode with this cone shaped rib
cage. If you connect the dots there and
imagine the belly of this. Big belly, very
stiff and immovable and this would shape
our ideas of locomotion and how these
things moved around and maybe even
digestive biology and so forth. Well, we
know from a whole lot of fossils that this
probably is no longer really an accurate
way to look at things. We have a number of
different vertebral columns that show that
the characteristic curvatures in the human
vertebral column that holds us upright
were present in early australopithecus.
There are lots of vertebrae in the lower
back so they can stand up fully upright.
So they're not that ape-like that way. And
there are new fossils that are bringing
new bits of data and I'll show you one of
those bits of data. This is a skeleton
called Kadanuumu, it means big man. It's
an australopithecus male and he's nice and
big. And we're very excited, those of us
who care about ribs are very excited
because it actually has some ribs. And you
can measure the curvature of those ribs to
say something about what maybe the rib
cage would have been like. And you see,
apes have this cone shaped rib cage of
very sort of straight ribs. Humans' curve
around, give you this more slender barrel
shape rib cage. You can measure this in
Kadanuumu and you can see it's right down
here with humans and gibbons who also have
this rib cage shape. Very different from
something we see in great apes and data
like these are giving us the picture that
in fact the body shape of australopithecus
may not have been so different from our
own as we had long thought. We also can
take a look at limb length. We have this
idea that australophitecus has more
ape-like limb proportions, longer upper
limbs, smaller lower limbs. Based partly
on good old Lucy here, Lucy is teeny tiny
so this is lower limb to upper limb. You
can pretty much pick your favorite
measure, it doesn't much matter. And you
can see that chimps and gorillas here have
bigger upper limbs than humans for their
lower limb size and Lucy seemed to fit
that picture. But new data like these ones
showed here again from Kadanuumu show that
once you get larger and fat,
australopithecus don't really have very
short legs. They maybe have longer arms,
but they don't really have short legs. And
Trent Holiday and other people have done
similar analyses to suggest that maybe the
lower limbs weren't that much shorter than
australopiths, they're just littler
animals. So they may not be as big a
change in limb length from australopiths
to Homo as we have thought. Another thing
we've learned recently comes from the
foot. An ape has a foot with not just a
grasping big toe, but the whole thing is
flexible, so it can wrap around branches
and hang on in the trees. Whereas our feet
are very stiff and they form a nice
propulsive lever to move us forward when
we walk on the ground on two feet, and
that propulsive lever is supported by
arches that go from front to back and side
to side that are built into the structure
of the bones of our foot. So one we lift
our heels off the ground, they stiffen up
and they let us work well. We've known for
a long time from fossil footprints that
australopithecus did not have a grasping
big toe. But recently, Bill Kimble and his
colleagues found this bone from the middle
part of the foot, it's called a metatarsal
and it shows us that the australopith
foot, just like what we see with maybe
Homo habilis or Homo erectus, had nicely
developed arches from front to back and
side to side, a fully modern human foot
really well adapted for long distance
travel on the ground. So this isn't really
maybe as different as we would have
thought a long time...or a number of years
ago as a difference between
australopithecus and human. And if you
blow up an australopith to be about the
same size you see this really fairly
human-like lower limb, fairly human like
body shape, and some of the other
differences maybe a little bit less
dramatic than we thought. So maybe this
transition isn't as dramatic as we thought
from the australopith side. What can we
now say about early Homo? We have now 2.8
million years ago we see the genus Homo
appear based on this jaw. That's only a
couple of hundred thousand years after
Lucy was roaming Ethiopia and it's a long
time ago, but it's just a jaw. I'm going
to talk about the post cranial fossils
associated with the origin of Homo. Right,
I'm done now. Thank you, have a nice day.
I'm out. So let's take a look at what we
actually have. We have quite a number
starting around two million years ago.
There are a whole lot of isolated post
cranial bones, bits of thigh and arm and
this and that and they're great. But
without heads and teeth we can't tell what
species they belong to. So they're not as
useful to us as we'd like. What about Homo
erectus? Well, when we find bones that are
associated with the heads and teeth we can
tell what species they belong to. These
are three skeletons and as you see as you
move over this way, I'm using the term
pretty liberally, associated bones of Homo
erectus from the beautiful Turkana boy
1808, 803 from Koobi Fora. But these are
all about a million and a half years ago.
That's over a million years after the
origins of the genus. The Dmanisi fossils
are a little bit older, 1.8, but that's
still a million years after the origin of
the genus Homo. Well, what about the other
early Homo species, habilis and
rudolfensis? These are the associated
skeletons we have for habilis. Looks a bit
like they were hit with an artillery
barrage, somewhat underwhelming but
they're a little bit older. Koobi 42.0,
Olduvai Gorge 1.8. There are some post
crania from the type side of Homo habilis.
The association with actual habilis has
been questioned by some people so they're
a little bit less certain in terms of
their taxonomic assignments but they are
there too, so we have some of those. What
about Homo rudolfensis post crania? That's
all we've got, right? We know absolutely
nothing about its skeleton which is
unfortunate. And so this whole exercise is
a bit like trying to squeeze blood from
turnips which either means it's really,
really hard or it means I can make
anything up and there's no data to falsify
it. That's all fine, too. But what can we
actually say about that supposed set of
characters that may seem to have gone
together with the origin of Homo. Well, we
can take a look at maybe body size and
Mark Rabowski and colleagues published
some new body size estimates and is there
really a difference between australopiths
and Homo? Well, when we look at
australopithecuses we see there's a pretty
good range in body size. They're not
particularly large, they're all fairly
similar. And when we look at Homo habilis
just a little bit more recent in time, we
only have a couple of specimens but they
fall right in that australopith range; not
particularly large. When we look at some
of these Homo erectus fossils that we know
are Homo erectus, even the Dmanisi
sample's really about similar to
australopithecus, you start to get a
little bit larger individuals but remember
again this is 1.5 million years ago. This
isn't very early in the evolution of the
genus. And so maybe we're saying, "Ah,
here's one that's trended increasing body
size happens." But we can look at the size
of some of these isolated fossils and
here's a fossil I'm going to talk about a
bit. It's a partial pelvis called 3228. It
was from somebody who is about as big as
the Turkana boy and it was 1.9 million
years ago. So what can we say about this?
There doesn't seem to be a great trend in
early evolution of Homo in either range of
body sizes or absolute body sizes. So
we're not seeing anything really dramatic
happening early in the origin of the genus
with body size and dimorphism. Well, what
about limb proportions and body build?
Well, when you're looking at the oldest
things like habilis it's a little hard to
do limb proportions when they're pretty
fragmentary. But what Chris Russell was
able to do is instead of looking at bone
length he was able to look at the bone
strength. And if you compare it to chimp,
you take the leg to the arm here and you
see they're pretty similar in strength.
They plot out about like this. Humans, the
lower limbs are stronger than the upper
limbs so they plot out up here. And he was
able to take these measurements for at
least the OH 62, the one in black here,
and put them on the graph with some Homo
erectuses and what you see is these two
Homo erectus skeletons are very human-like
in their strength proportions, but Homo
habilis is not. Homo habilis seems to have
a different build. And actually when you
take the very few measurements you could
take on this scrappy specimen, it also
seems to have a little bit larger upper
limbs relative to lower limbs than we tend
to see in humans and maybe in these Homo
erectus. The Dmanisi sample,
interestingly, doesn't seem to have the
sort of proportions. It seems to be more
like the erectus although the same studies
haven't been done. So there seems to be
some sort of a difference here between
habilis and erectus perhaps in body
proportion, given how fragmentary the
fossil evidence is. This is an interesting
fossil I want to mention because Meave
Leakey and her colleagues found this in
2009, actually fit on this bit was found
in 1980 which is kind of cool. And it's
associated piece of pelvis and femur, but
this captures the hip joint. And the hip
joint is interesting partly because we
have a bunch of them in the fossil record
but partly because the hip joint seems to
be a place that there isn't a lot of
difference among these early Homo species
as best we can say. Here's the 3228 pelvis
again. In this pelvis shows a series of
features that we only see in humans, we
never see in australopithecus, so it's not
a bad hypothesis for a Homo. These two are
almost dead ringers for one another but
this one is just much smaller. So either
these are a male and female of a really
dimorphic species or they're two species
that happen to look the same. But they're
both 1.9 million years old so they're nice
and early. Well, when we look at those
Homo-like features, we see them in this
5881, pardon me, this new specimen here.
So here's Lucy and you look at the front
border of the ileum, part of the pelvis
it's straight and every australopith we
have is bent in every Homo that we have
and it's bent in 5881. When we look at the
ileum from the side you could see this
buttress called the iliac pillar here is
more vertical and set back from the edge
of the bone and it's big. In the Homo
pelvises, it's very weak in every
australopith and angled right into the
front of the bone. In 5881 here is looking
like Homo. So this looks kind of like a
Homo sort of a creature. When we look at
the other side of the hip joint at the
proximal femur, every time you see an
australopith that has a relatively small
femural head. So relatively small hip
joint. You see that in the pelvis too,
where Homo, including modern humans, have
a much a larger femural head. 5881 needs a
little bit of digital reconstruction which
you can do actually for quite accurately
using CAD software, it also would have had
a large femural head, and we can see them
in the pelvis too. And it's interesting
that every femur we have that seems to be
Homo, attributed or not, has a big femural
head. In every australopithecus we have
which is associated with post cranials has
a small one. So this seems to be a feature
that characterize all Homo, not related
perhaps to body proportions. So changes in
body proportion, change in hip joint size
don't seem to co-occur in early Homo.
Well, again, squeezing blood out of more
turnips here, we can come back to our bone
cross sectional shape. And this is more
work by Chris Ruff Mosley, so you can take
a femur, you can slice it open in the
middle and you can look at these sections.
And everything we have that we know or
suspect is Home erectus, actual Homo
erectus that we have data for has this mid
shaft femur is very wide from side to side
and short from front to back. And it has a
really indistinct marking on the back of
the femur for attachment of muscles. When
you put Homo habilis on there, it's a very
different shape; rounder and it's longer
from front to back. 5881 is a dead ringer
for OH 62 in this feature and they both
also have this big, thick attachment here
for those thigh muscles. So, ah, you say,
maybe this is Homo habilis, maybe 5881 is
habilis, that's great. But if you put data
that Phil Whitemyer kindly lent me from
the Dmanisi skeletons, they are actually
shaped like the habilis also. Now either
this says that Dmanisi is not Homo erectus
which I really wouldn't want to say based
on one character here, or something else
is going on. Chris Roth's idea about the
explanation for these differences is that
in Homo erectus, when the pelvis gets
bigger to accommodate larger brains, the
whole body gets wider and that puts more
medialateral bending stresses on the bone
and so they're wider to accommodate that.
So that this shape would indicate a
narrower body form than this shape. Well,
we can look at little bit of pelvic shape
and turn 5881. You can take this curvature
here which gives you a little bit of an
idea of the inlet. You could see
australopithecus very wide, a little wider
in Homo erectus and then these are later
Homo things, but 5881 it seems to be
narrower, which seems to fit with Chris'
hypothesis about the explanation for the
femural bone shapes. In which case,
perhaps then, Dmanisi may have had a
narrower shape than we see in East African
Homo erectus. Does this mean it's not Homo
erectus? It's hard to say. Remember that
Dmanisi individuals are 300,000 years
older than the Homo erectus individuals I
have on this graph. That's a long time.
Think about what happened in the
neanderthals and humans in the last 50,000
or 100,000 years. So this could be
something happening through time. It could
be species related. It's very hard to say
given how scrappy the fossil evidence is.
But it does say that some of these
characters aren't necessarily co-varying
and there seem to be different morphotypes
within the genus Homo. All Homo doesn't
look like all the other Homo from the neck
down. And that's an important factor to
think about when we then constructing our
adaptive explanations for what's going on
in this transition from australopithecus
to Homo. So we have these creatures that
may be not quite as stocky as we thought.
The lower limbs may have been much better
adapted for decent amounts or quality of
travel while on the ground, and they may
not have been as ape like as we've
previously thought with australopithecus.
When we look at the earliest Homo, we may
see at least some that may have even more
apey limb proportions than we see in
australopithecus. We see that the
combination of features of having larger
lower limb joints, of having larger limb
joints, longer lower limbs don't
necessarily co-vary. Limbs were already
long, hip joints may have been gotten big
at the beginning of Homo, it's hard to
say. Body form may have evolved
differently in different species and/or at
different times. But we no longer have
this idea of one change associated with
the origin of the genus. And these well
adapted features that we see here that
make this complex, that make Homo erectus
great that do things like hunting and tool
using and everything later, may be
something that weren't associated with the
origin of the genus but came in much
later. So in fact, if we compare
australopithecus to earliest Homo, this
might be a more reasonable picture to have
in our mind. Animals that weren't really
very different especially from the neck
down, weren't really different in
locomotor capabilities. If I had more
reconstructions of different Homo species
you might have seen them look a little bit
different from one another. But basically,
the picture is that there's not a dramatic
change here in the origin of Homo that has
anything to do with the post cranial
skeleton. Perhaps the adaptive changes
associated with the origin of the genus
had to do more with diet, other behaviors
or something else. And that's what we need
to be thinking that what happened to the
origin of Homo that gave rise to all the
other great things that we've been hearing
about today. I say thank you.
♪ [music] ♪